OK, David Pakman dotcom slash discord is where
we are.
Let's go to Alec from the United Kingdom.
Alec, you're on the air.
Hello.
Yes, that's you.
Oh, I just don't life I would be the first,
but I'm sorry about up.
Hello.
Yes, I'm from the U.K. I guess my question
would be mainly about coming in, because obviously
I did send buttons, just got in with Komala,
looking forward to twenty twenty with the
I think I'm not sure which seats go up.
I think if the Congress and Senate.
Right.
So for 20/20, is there some third voice in
the background right now and between you and
I.
It might be L.A., No.
So every two years, all 435 House seats are
up for reelection and one third of Senate
seats.
So that's what's up in 2022.
OK, so I guess the question would be, do you
think do you think that Republicans would
have like a high chance of reclaiming seats,
especially off the top of the party?
I did I did a video about this, actually.
Typically when when the White House switches
party, the next midterm is bad for the winning
party.
But I think that circumstances are very different
this time.
The Senate seats up for reelection aren't
particularly bad for Democrats.
And it's a real question.
My hope is that a lot of these Kuhnen conspiracy
theorists like Lauren Bobert and Marjorie
Taylor Green.
My hope is that they will be one term Fluke's
and that they will lose in twenty, twenty
two.
So I think it's quite plausible that Democrats
do OK in the midterms.
OK, that the moderate Republican seats up
for grabs.
Do you think Democrats have any chances of
slipping those?
Yes, I don't have the Senate list in front
of me and there's many in the House.
But Will we'll look at that in more detail
as we get closer to the midterms.
No, I have to say but I'm curious, what are
you what are you doing?
Are you cooking or what are you working on
right now?
I'm doing I mean, I just right now I'm just
reading the really well my dissertation.
And you're not in you're not in a factory
or anything.
It could be just help out by my friend is
OK.
You are using a book basically some got it
books.
And so that's all right.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate the call.
No worries.
Thank you, David.
Pleasure.
Absolute, absolute and complete.
Complete pleasure.